hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
Medicare's new national coverage
determination for next-generation
sequencing what does it mean for
diagnostic laboratories presented by
Roger Cline Princeville Roger decline MD
JD consulting Cleveland Clinic chair
professional relations committee
Association for molecular pathology and
medical director molecular oncology
I am Alexis Krause of lappers and I will
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's labret is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I would like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located in the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen once there's many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the help desk button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen or use the
ask a question box to let us know that
you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Klein I will now turn the presentation
over to him Thank You Alexis and good
morning everybody so today we're going
to talk about a national coverage
determination that it's critical to the
future of molecular pathology in in
oncology and it's very very important
also for the advancement of these from
next-generation sequencing in clinical
laboratory practice the submitter of the
next of the national coverage
determination that we're going to
discuss today was a company called
foundation medicine many of you may have
heard
Foundation medicine and their foundation
one test the foundation one test was the
subject of the national coverage
determination that the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services made for
next-generation sequencing so the
foundation one CDX tests that that's the
the proper name for the test is a
next-generation sequence sequencing in
vitro diagnostic test that detects
substitutions insertions deletions
alterations and copy number changes in
324 genes it it can detect certain or
select rearrangements and genomic
signatures that include microsatellite
instability and tumor emotional burden
it's performed on DNA isolated from
formalin-fixed paraffin-embedded tumor
tissue specimens so let's first start
with the Medicare payment criteria under
the law ID under the law items or
services to be paid by Medicare must be
reasonable and necessary for the
diagnosis or treatment of illness or
injury or to improve the functioning of
a melam body member in other words
Medicare services must be adjudged
reasonable and necessary so CMS is the
one the agency the the payor who makes
that determination and the way the
entrance they evaluate whether the
product or services improves patient
health outcomes you may have heard the
term clinical utility and that's
commonly used to describe the the
features and process that that the
agency goes through and making these
decisions so in truth or in reality in
practice most of the Medicare decisions
are made by individual Medicare
contractors there's 13 of them scattered
throughout the United States so most of
the coverage determinations or coverage
decisions I'm on services for Medicare
and particularly lab services about
which we're speaking are made by these
local contractors and these are again
Medicare intermediary
whoo-hooo process the claims and may
coverage determination ah so
occasionally sometimes once in a while
Medicare the agency makes additional
coverage determination this means that
rather than having a coverage
determination by a local contractor that
that affects only the entities within
the contractors jurisdiction
CMS's or the the Medicare agency's
determination will apply to the entire
country it will apply nationwide and so
another interesting feature is that the
FDA the Food Drug Administration and the
certain Center for Medicare and Medicaid
Services have gotten together and
developed a program for parallel review
of medical devices what happens in this
program is that Medicare in making a
coverage decision or determination will
will talk to the the spot early while
the sponsor is going through the FDA
approval process and what this is
intended to do is to speed up the the
approval process for payment by the
agency interacts with the company
interacts with FDA and attempts to get
the the information it needs in order to
make a payment decision the the most no
in most cases a test goes through the
FDA process and then or any other
service and then gets approved for
payment afterwards so that that process
typically starts later but in this case
the CMS and and after you have gotten
together and designed a process that
will allow review to take place
concurrently or at least communication
to take place concurrently now there's
only been one previous test before this
this foundation one test that has gone
through the parallel review program so
so foundation one went through this
program this was a this was a concurrent
or joint
of FDA Medicare effort to get this test
both approved and and paid for and it's
only again the second fest it's gone
through that process the first was a
colon cancer screening test by exact
Sciences so CMS came out yes on in
November the the the foundation one test
was approved by the FDA so after you
approved fundation one test and
immediately then CMS came out with a
proposed national coverage determination
now what what they did was rather than
making that coverage determination
specific to the foundation once they
made the coverage determination based on
next-generation sequencing on the
methodology used by the foundation one
test and they and just a quote from the
from the coverage decision the the
evidence is sufficient to cover
next-generation sequencing is a
diagnostic laboratory test so you can
see here what CMS did was they made an G
they made the coverage decision or
determination for NGS particular concern
was was a provision that disallowed
payment for laboratory developed NGSS so
it for routine purposes so effectively
only tests that could get reimbursed
would be those that were FDA approved
there were also additional requirements
for coverage with evidence development
so essentially research is part of the
Medicare payment process and people
objected that as well it was quite
cumbersome and and and would have been
extremely difficult to implement
well the CMS listened and was responsive
to the comments and actually removed the
the stricture against payment for
laboratory developed tests those those
will not fall within the national
coverage determination however those
decisions will be made at the local
level by the local contractors just as
they have been foundation medicines test
was approved for for payment and they in
fact they they even brought in the the
indications for for use of the test and
the stage at which patience the stage of
cancer at which patients can can
actually receive the testing yet and and
have it paid for by Medicare so so they
they bridge and and removed remove the
the stricture against not paying
laboratory labs that designed their own
test but but maintained coverage only
for at the national level only for
fda-approved yes so let's go over what
the coverage determination or NGS says
well first they're they're they're
really three components the first is the
patient characteristics and so what
we're talking about here are recurrent
relapsed/refractory metastatic basically
stage three or four cancer so so cancer
that spread beyond the immediate tumor
this was broadened it used the original
proposal said only Stage four I see not
previously tested using the same next
generation sequencing test for the same
primary diagnosis of cancer or repeating
using the same NGS stuff only when a new
primary cancer diagnosis is made and
then finally the patient has to decide
to seek further cancer treatment for
example chemotherapy the second
component is the characteristics of the
test so the test has to be FDA cleared
or approved as a companion in vitro
diagnostic test and FDA approved or
cleared have have an FDA approved or
cleared indication for use in that
particular patients type of cancer and
then the results have to be provided to
a treating physician for management of
the patient using a report template
template that specifies treatment
options so we have the patient the best
characteristics and then there's the
local coverage determinations again we
should we saw those local contractors
those 13 contractors spread throughout
the United States up there they also
have criteria on which they're supposed
to rely again it's it's the same
recurrent relapsed/refractory metastatic
at stage three or four cancer not
previously tested using the same test
and then the patient has to decide to
see further cancer treatment so the
coverage the basis for the coverage
determinations under the local
contractors is the same as under the
national contractors but for the FDA
component so the first question we have
to ask ourselves that this is a pretty
confusing neck it's a pretty confusing
national coverage determination the the
the the the published document itself is
about 150 pages and the FIR butts the
first question I think many of us wonder
ask is next generation sequencing really
a test is it appropriate to make a a
coverage determination based on on a
methodology are we covering a test and I
think you can tell by this screen the
answer is no what you have here are six
different tests used in cancer for five
next-generation sequencing and every one
of them is different they could they
test different things different items
actually the tests in the upper in the
upper right corner is actually for
cystic fibrosis the others are cancer
tests but there are they all test
different things so what we're saying
here is no next generation sequencing
isn't a test it's actually a method and
and that can cause some problems in
trying to understand and interpret this
national coverage determination Oh
so starting with with because the basis
for the determination is the FDA
approval you can't read this
determination alone it has to be read in
conjunction with the FDA approval for
the foundation one companion diagnostics
passed or for any of the other
fda-approved test you have to understand
what the FDA approval is so the first
point is that this test is intended as a
companion diagnostic but identify
patients who may benefit from treatment
with the targeted therapies listed in
table one in accordance with approved
therapeutic product labeling table one
is a provided list of drugs which will
which I'll show you on the next slide
when a companion
it really means in fda jargon is that
the test is is essential for proper
utilization of a medication so for
example you look at a targeted drug
difficult ation here FEC for example and
and that the test the best for that
mutation is integral to the use of the
drug and that's what a what to FDA a
companion diagnostic is and there there
a several companion diagnostic tests and
and they're different I mean foundation
medicine is 324 genes there's a very
small number of genes in the on combined
diagnostic target test the little over
twenty it's smaller number in the Praxis
extended Rast panel
less fewer than twenty the foundation
focus companion dynamics comparing
diagnostic fear CHS is only brca1 and
brca2 so so heterogeneity in these tests
and then finally you have one test by
sloan-kettering Memorial sloan-kettering
the msk impact test that test was not
was not approved it was either different
processes approval is a more rigorous
much more expensive process than than
clearance which which rather than
determining safety and efficacy finds
the test of substantially equivalent to
a a predicate device or some other means
by which it's it doesn't undergo a full
safety and efficacy evaluation it's it's
considered lower risk and and requires
less less data and and less study for
for approval but the next part of the
test of the FDA's approval
Adso adds a real wrinkle to it but
additionally the foundation one
companion test is intended to provide
tumor mutation profiling to be used by
qualified healthcare professionals in
accordance with professional guidelines
in a college of solid malignant neoplasm
but we had here is you have first you
have these companion diagnostic
indications that we saw on the previous
slide drugs matched with with particular
mutation
but here after you get it another
criteria and it's basically it's
approved for mutation profiling based on
professional guidelines and you can
imagine that this in practice may be
somewhat hard to sort out so how do we
interpret FDA clearance or approval
requirements well first of all today
text FDA has not cleared through that
through that lesser process I mentioned
any companion diagnostic test they've
all been considered high-risk class
three and they've had had to establish
safety and efficacy or safety and
effectiveness um so so that so we don't
really know what this means in that
context and then what a CMS mean by an
FDA approved or cleared indication for
use in that patient's cancer what is
what is what does the agency mean by a
what what does it appear that approved
or cleared indication for use when if we
look back the FDA approval says mutation
profiling which is very broad in
accordance with professional guidelines
okay
so sorry
and then does does CMS's added
requirement of fda-approved or cleared
indication or use or to a companion
diagnostic use that we talked about is
it tied only to a drug because it has to
be does their requirements that the FDA
approved or cleared indication for use
he has to be for one of these companion
diagnostics or for one of the approved
in that table or could it be another
drug mutation pair can it be some other
drug or mutation pair that ends up in a
guideline or could it be something else
entirely
that isn't a drug mutation here we don't
know um
what professional guidelines are useful
we don't know that either is it is it
the National Comprehensive Cancer
Network guidelines that's one that's
commonly used by insurers what about the
American Society for Clinical Oncology
they make guidelines there's lots of
guideline producing bodies what
guidelines are acceptable and then what
what must a guideline say um as an
example look at the National
Comprehensive Cancer Network guidelines
NCCN in one of the recommendations for
thyroid carcinoma they say consider
molecular diagnostics we have sufficient
mus the guidelines specifically
recommend a particular gene mutation or
next-generation sequencing we don't know
the answer to that they're going to to
have to sort that out and making payment
determination and then does you have a
situation here we talked about approval
versus clearance foundation one is 324
genes but only a small number of those
are actually known to be useful for
making therapeutic decisions it's it was
considered class three it went through
what's called pre-market approval it was
safety and if effectiveness was
established and then you have the mfk
impact that i mentioned that has 468
genes again the same same issue only a
small number are clinically known to be
useful for therapeutic decision making
but because it because the claims were
different it wasn't it wasn't go through
as a companion diagnostic it was
considered class two less less risky
than then then the class three
foundation test not a true companion
diagnostic and and so it went through a
less rigorous process called clearance
um
but in the end SDA looks at the
analytical performance how well it
detects mutations in both in in the
class too as well as the class three
test it's really a more of a rigorous
more more rigorous clinical judgment
under the class three test so what's the
justification for for requiring FDA
approval versus clearance if we if FDA
has looked at this and says okay that
msk impact test performs very well if it
analytically performs well and we
already know that what the companion
diagnostics are do we need approval so
so and we again we don't know what what
what CMS is going yet approved you're
cleared but we really don't know FDA has
not it has not cleared a companion
diagnostic um and then the question is
we you're talking about a single
companion diagnostic seems all required
by the language of the of the
origination and it wouldn't be treated
any different you know if you look at
the plain language then nine different
companion diagnostics for example um and
then and and then and then the question
is the tumor profiling you have to have
the tumor profiling indications and what
is that what exactly does that mean and
can it be in a completely different gene
can you ever compare and you can there
be a companion diagnostic for : and then
to use in thyroid because there's a
tumor tumor profiling indication in a
guideline we don't know the answer to
this question
other ambiguities what is the same NGS
test me does the same test mean an
identical test or a test for a companion
analyte is is if you if the patient's
tested for if a colon cancer patients
tested for Rast testing up and it does
that is is that identical or or do you
mean the the specific test what if your
tested by a test for that has fifty
mutation can you is the if the does that
rule out the use of the larger test or
is it okay because EFT itself is an
identical
even though the the clinically valuable
analytes already tested for its its it's
somewhat confusing the other question is
are very confusing actually and the
other question is is how does this apply
to he mode hematopoietic or blood-borne
malignancies leukemias lymphomas how do
you treat it relative to solid tumors
for which the the coverage determination
is is most clearly directed um and lest
you think that that these are just
nitpicking or minor issues I have on the
screen a coverage determination from
from the MOL DX program by Palmetto
which which covers a large number of
patients in the United States and you
can see here their their coverage
decision for non small cell lung cancer
looks it looks at whether patients have
been previously tested for for example
EGFR mutations al rearrangements roster
arrangement and they don't allow payment
unless the patient has has been negative
for these so it isn't a moot point as to
to what what constitutes the same test
when you have a contractor that's
already making decisions based upon
previous mutation testing and again
these are going to be the ones that are
most significant can the patient be
tested for those that are about which
everything about which the knowledge is
known all the companion diagnostics and
then and then go get the bigger test can
you and get paid for both another
concern with this with this coverage
determination yes for the Medicare
program in expansion and cost because
the the incentive here is to because
because it's a very large expensive test
paid the assent incentive is to drive
testing to that more larger more
expensive death and so the foundation
one test which has been paid under a CPT
code eight one four or five five is
almost three thousand dollars the
smaller test smaller tumor tests such as
the other fda-approved tests are are
paid under eight one four four five
which is about six hundred dollars so
you have
very large difference in test and the
coverage of termination is is has the
provided incentives to switch to the
more expensive test is this going to be
a problem for the program the other
question is you're going to have an
opportunity to use a lot more drugs
either off-label or potentially enroll
patients in trials but there will be an
increase in off-label use based on the
foundation medicine stats and that is
also these drugs can be very expensive
and and so that also can create strains
for the program so is is Medicare going
to going to end up relook looking at
this again after more data comes out
it's it's not clear finally and lastly
the questionnaire point is what are the
local coverage what are the local
contractors going to do you have on the
screen you have a screen shot of
Palmetto Palmetto gbas moldy X program
ball DX mu DX is a it is a national
rollout of this contractors process for
determination of of coverage for
coverage determinations okay so so the
[ __ ] you see in front of you is slide by
meadow from the Palmetto GBAS Multi X
program this is a national program that
now is used by seven out of the thirteen
Medicare contractors but I believe
twenty-six states to make coverage
condition so by one contract or multi X
then there's there there are a few other
contractors they're all going to have to
make determinations both on the
laboratory developed tests which fruit
which are the bulk of the test most
naturalisation sequencing tests are
laboratory developed these contract you
have to decide how to pay them when to
pay them and and they're also going to
have to decide I some of the fine points
of implementation of the national
coverage determination with respect to
foundation medicines
the foundation one test now the the much
of much of that is going to be done by
Palmetto foundation medicine is in
palmettos jurisdiction so so they're
going to they're going to with respect
to foundation medicine Palmetto is going
to be the ones calling the shots for how
to interpret some of these fine points
some of the questions I raised likely in
conjunction with central CMS and and
that's going to be the same for for
those local contractors that that use
Palmetto GBAS multi X program to make
decisions they're they're going to mul
DX is going to be determined what what
what tests are covered and then what
indications what situations and with
likely with some direction from CMS
central and then there'll be other
contractors and they're going to have to
make their own determinations so with
that I thank you dr. Klein for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left your
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen well answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question is if a
Medicare contractor disagrees with a
national coverage determination and the
local contractor overruled the NCD well
the answer is no and it's so the the
national coverage determination in so
far is what what the Centers for
Medicare and Medicaid Services determine
that it says and and how its to be
implemented the contractor must follow
that but but the scope of what's beyond
is is within the contractors domain our
next question is if a service falls
outside of the scope of a Medicare
national coverage determination who
decides whether or not it is covered
the Medicare program or the contractor
yes so this is a follow-on to the
previous question again it's sort of
asking in the same way you're the if CMS
determines what's within the confines of
the scope of that national coverage
determination whatever falls outside
it's going to be decided by the
contractor CMS is not going to get
involved generally typically most
circumstances is not going to get
involved the contractor is going to make
those determinations itself dr. Klein
which Medicare contractor makes the
local coverage determination Forest
Service is it the contractor
jurisdiction where the patient or
ordering physician is located or the
contractor in the jurisdiction where the
laboratory service provider resides yeah
that's a great question and that goes
back to what I was talking about with
with foundation medicine in Palmetto so
so the way the coverage the way the
system works the coverage determinations
are made where the lab is situated and
you can see that makes a lot of sense
because the the lanced performing the
same test over and over again where
patients throughout the country are
getting an array of tests from array of
different providers and it wouldn't
sense to have of everybody making all
these different decisions so so it's so
for a national laboratory it's going to
be the decisions are going to be made
within the jurisdiction that that the
contractor operates off you you know
wherever are the provider operates
wherever they have their lab is that
that contractors can make those
determinations does the term companion
diagnostic refer to the gene or mutation
tested or a specific test from a
specific manufacturer yes so I could go
on about this issue for hours you don't
have them but it's a really critical one
so we so according to FDA they FDA is
created it's an FDA creation has created
this this this class of tests called the
companion diagnostic it refers to a
specific test for a specific analyte we
have argued at the Association for
molecular pathology for years what
really talking about is a companion
analyte you should worry about the
analyte not not business to the test
and just keep be aware of what the the
performance characteristics are for
detection of the specific analyte but
but you shouldn't really need to go to a
clinical trial to reprove that analyte
and and really to to to try to obtain
clinical information in the context of
of the of an analyte that's well known
but but that isn't how FDA season so
their FDA's the FDA's definition of a
companion diagnostic is the specific
test so it's not the analyte it's a PRF
v600e it's not EGFR mutations and non
small cell lung cancer and it isn't a
race and Cola it's the specific best for
those mutations and dr. Klein it looks
like we have time for one more question
which guidelines will CMS use to
determine whether or not a test has an
FDA approved or cleared indication
anybody that we don't know so so they
cited than in some of the references the
National Comprehensive Cancer Network
guideline these these guidelines are
commonly used I think they're the most
commonly used by payers though that's my
impression although I don't have have
literature for it that would be my my
suspicion and and I and and that may be
one American Society for Clinical
Oncology
without excellent guidelines and there
are many many there are a number of
organizations that put out really good
guidelines for for diagnostic testing
and in cancer with NGS we don't know the
answer specify which which guidelines
would be used and again this is a this
is a challenge for the for the for the
process we really don't we can't read
this guidance or this this document that
that this coverage determination and
fully understand what it means because
we don't have specific answers to these
questions I would like to once again
thank dr. Klein for his presentation I
would also like to thank laberd's for
making today's education
webcast possible before we go I would
like to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through July of 2018 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and we hope to see you again soon
goodbye thank you